[Música]
y es que en nuestro tema del día
hablamos precisamente de la previa a la
conferencia de la onu sobre el clima de
la venta y 6 que empieza este domingo en
glasgow en escocia los líderes mundiales
activistas por el clima expertos en la
crisis climática van a discutir esta
hoja de ruta para seguir en los próximos
años para tratar de frenar el
calentamiento global y además reducir
las emisiones de carbono para ello
quiero saludar en este momento a nuestro
segundo imitables mauricio lópez es
director ejecutivo de la red colombiana
de pacto global de las naciones unidas-
novicio gracias por tu tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 qué planes se tienen ustedes
con activistas en la cob 26 para hacer
un poco más de presión ante todos estos
líderes
bueno primero un gran saludo a todos
ustedes muy interesantes la charla
previa donde en vuestra parte de los
efectos de la crisis climática
unas ideas fuerza muy importante acá va
a aparecer un pequeño estudio pequeño no
creo pero corto por grande en lo que
implica que hay países como colombia
guatemala honduras nicaragua haití y en
américa latina están entre los que son
enormemente vulnerables a los efectos
físicos de la crisis climática y que
tienen dificultades en su adaptación ese
es un primer gran mensaje segundo
mensaje colombia colombia le está
apostando fuertemente a una acción
climática para tratar de mitigar desde
una manera efectiva y lograr cumplir las
metas del gobierno nacional establecido
una metas del 51 por ciento de reducción
de gases de efecto invernadero donde uno
de los mayores componentes o dígase bien
está en la lucha frontal contra la
deforestación
pero es la meta nuestra 0 hectáreas
deforestadas al 2030 el estar ya
colombia inicialmente haya propuesto 21
20 por ciento de reducción de gases y el
gobierno nacional hace un año la
incremento al 51 por ciento pero voy a
hablar de lo que ustedes preguntan es
distancia que hacemos es de pacto global
para
proponer a una acción frente al tema de
que de lucha contra el cambio climático
y la mejor respuesta es lo que se ha
impulsado y que hemos denominado el
acelerador el clima y ambition
acelerator en inglés se buscando
acelerar las ambiciones de la lucha
contra el cambio climático es un
programa dirigido a las empresas
que están afiliadas a pacto global en el
mundo son alrededor de 16 mil
organizaciones alrededor de 200 empresas
con un concepto nuevo objetivos basados
en la ciencia
y crear un camino claro para abordar la
transición de las organizaciones al ser
honesto o sea la descarbonización se
esto implica que las compañías tienen
que tener implementar programas de
reducción de ventas de emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero qué tan
lejos o qué tan cerca estamos nosotros
entonces de reducir esas emisiones en
nuestra región en américa latina que
porque para eso se necesita además un
gran plan económico para poder apoyar no
a estas empresas y también el gobierno
que tan lejos que tan cerca estamos
mauricio
a ver yo hacemos en francos
estamos en una visión optimista pero con
un realismo absoluto qué quiere decir
eso que empezamos que haya una acción
mundial que también ayuda a estos países
para con recursos para poder afrontar
fuertemente esta acción porque solos
estos países por más esfuerzo que las
empresas quieren hacer entre los mismos
gobiernos no pueden por eso es
interesante una carta que colombia puede
estar migrando y que con otros países y
es que si vamos cumpliendo nuestras
metas
de pronto lograr efectos de reducción
del valor de la deuda o incluso la
condonación que eso podría ser una
acción muy importante en un momento
determinado otro elemento es que nos
ayuden a aumentar fuertemente la
participación en procesos de
investigación
aumentando los valores de colombia
debemos aumentar
de casi 2 billones de pesos en dólares
aunque 500 mil millones 500 millones
medio millón de dólares para solo metas
a la investigación en temas de
mitigación adaptación en el cambio
climático en un país como colombia todos
los recursos se requieren muchos el país
está impulsando y puesto a carbono está
impulsando cambios en la forma como se
va moviendo el proceso pero la plata no
alcanza y necesitamos el apoyo y el
compromiso de las demás naciones con
financiamiento blando o con condonación
con un apoyo investigación y con
cooperación mauricio hablemos ahora de
cara a la cob 26 que se va a realizar va
a empezar a realizarse este domingo en
clase con 9 en escocia le quiero
preguntar si en esta oportunidad si se
van a ver más cambios más acción real de
cara pues a la anterior cumbre esta está
en los acuerdos de parís de 2015 que
realmente como que no se vio muy bien
implementado en los países y sobre todo
en américa latina'
bueno recordemos que la cobre parece la
con 21 esta es la con 26 o sea son cinco
más que significa expectativas yo soy un
optimista
frente al hecho que hay un cambio de
liderazgo en algunos países donde ya el
tema ambiental y el tema de de la
ambición climática empieza a tener una
fortaleza importante por supuesto
hablando también de los eeuu si esto
puede jalonar de una manera efectiva una
mayor ambición sin embargo sin embargo
el tema de la pandemia nos retrotrajo
porque los indicadores de crecimiento
económico se vinieron para abajo con
aumento de desempleo con un aumento de
pobreza en los indicadores con
inequidades absolutas entonces hay una
dificultad desde la realidad económica
para poder afrontar una mayor dinámica
frente a mayores reducciones porque eso
implica una cuestión mayor sin embargo
soy optimista de que va a haber una
apuesta fuerte a la movilización
sostenible
seguir apostándole a la transición
energética con la descarbonización de la
economía sí y que muchos países
aumenten sus ambiciones climáticas en
eso fundamentalmente necesitamos que la
china y eeuu líder en esa visión de
cambio hay algunas personas que no son
tan optimistas
pero yo creo que todo como mundo debemos
exigirle a nuestros líderes que todos
tengamos ambición climática o sea
ambición para resolver llegar máximo a
la meta de 1.5 de lo contrario como bien
lo necesita su nota anterior estaremos
condenados a muchas más muertes muchos
más desplazados más pobreza más
contaminación y al final de cuentas
tenemos que llegar a tomar medidas más
dramáticas si esto es cierto que es una
oportunidad que no debiéramos perder
mauricio y me quedo con su entusiasmo no
de cara a esta crisis climática que
estamos viviendo porque el optimismo y
pues también las acciones que nosotros
hagamos como ciudadanos pues va a
contribuir de alguna manera si sea
pequeña pues no destruirnos como
humanidad y como planeta mauricio
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en directo américa
a ustedes muchas gracias y recuerden el
vaso hay que mirarlo más que medio lleno
pero hay que buscar el agua para llenar